السياسه الجديده لربما في الساعه الاخيره
التي انتهجتها اسرائيل
بقصف منازل فلسطينيه حيث تهدف قبل ساعه من
الان منزل مكون من ثلاث طوابق في منطقه
القراره شرق خان يونس جنوب قطاع غزه ومنزل
اخر يتبع لعائله المصري في بيت لاهيا
وربما هذا نهج جديد تبع قبل ساعه من الان
بعد تركيز اسرائيل لقصفها على
اراض او منصات لاطلاق الصواريخ ومقدرات
تتبع لي الفصائل العسكريه الفلسطينيه
وتحديدا الجهاد الاسلامي بالتاكيد كان
هناك رد من قبل الجهاد الاسلامي ويمكننا
القول بانه تحذير
كلامي جاء على لسان قاده في الجهاد
الاسلامي بان اتجاه اسرائيل نحو سياسه قصف
المنازل
للفلسطيني
معلومات اكثر عن هذه المنازل وقاطنيها
كذلك التي استهد فتها اسرائيل في الساعه
الاخيره كما تفضلتي
لا اصابات يعني في القصف الاخير الذي طال
منزلين واحد في شرق خان يونس جنوب قطاع
غزه والاخر في شمال قطاع غزه
لاصابات ولكن المنازل سويت بالارض بالكامل
خاصه وانها استهدفت من قبل الطيران الحربي
الاسرائيلي الجهاد الاسلامي حذرت وبشكل
واضح بان تحول اسرائيل نحو هذه السياسه
باستهدافها للمنازل سيقابل بتكثيف لقصف
بالصواريخ سيصل لتل ابيب وللعمق
الاسرائيلي ولكن الساعه الاخيره بعد هذا
القصف لم يذكر انه تم استهداف اي من منازل
الفلسطينيين اسرائيل وفي اخر ما رشح عن
مصادرها تقول باننا بانها قصفت او استهدفت
133 هدفا في غزه يتبعون
لمواقع
ومخازن انتاج اسلحه ومقدرات تحت ارضيه
تتبع للفصائل العسكريه الفلسطينيه وبالاخص
بالجهاد الاسلامي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات